stop listening to compliments I'm tired
of telling you to not worry about haters
and trolls and negative opinions I'm
actually flipping the script on
you and I'm gonna yell at push at try to
inspire communicate a perspective for
you to stop hearing the cheering the
reason so many struggle with negativity
is because they overvalue positive
reinforcement you're addicted to people
telling you you're pretty you're
addicted to people telling you you're
good at basketball you're addicted to
parents and teachers telling you you're
a good student you're addicted to
opinions once you learn how to not
overvalue somebody who's commending or
complimenting you is the second you go
down the path of dealing with the
reverse